[Música]
[Aplausos]
desde que somos pequeños buscamos
nuestra independencia que ponernos que
nos gusta cuando vamos entrando a la
adolescencia
queremos nuestro espacio y ya entrando a
la madurez nuestra independencia
económica y ahí es donde empieza la
cuestión
esta charla es para hacer lo que más me
gusta que es cuestionar la dogma es
decir la proposición que se asienta por
fin me siento y cierta como principio
innegable
pero pasándolo a criollo es que soy muy
porfiados
tanto que hace no mucho me fui de
vacaciones a una isla muy muy chiquitita
y pasé un buen rato discutiendo con una
persona de unos cincuenta y tantos de
años
acerca de que del otro lado de la isla
según yo había una playa muy linda a lo
que la persona me decía no yo soy nativo
y no hay nada del otro lado
y bueno ha sido porfiados hoy
yo creo que nada está escrito en piedra
y que cuanto antes detectemos los
cambios mejor nos podemos preparar
excepto lo de la isla que tenía razón el
hombre y del otro lado solamente habían
piedras
en este momento hay un auge muy
importante de emprendedores esto un poco
debido a la tecnología que les permitió
competir con las grandes empresas casi
de igual a igual y por muy poco dinero a
simple vista parece algo muy bueno todo
por ganar muy poco riesgo pero es
realmente esto así
les voy a pedir que levanten la mano
cuantos trataron de tener un
emprendimiento o algún negocio propio
y cuantos aún lo tienen bastante menos
bueno
a menudo vienen amigos familiares
colegas y me
dicen che claudio como tenés tu negocio
propio quiero hacer esto a ver qué te
parece y cuando lo empiezo a mirar me
doy cuenta a simple vista que hay
errores muy básicos casi como si
quisieran hacer una casa y empezarán por
el techo
por el otro lado
vienen otros que traen un anteproyecto
análisis de costo hasta empiezan a
funcionar y dan 23 tumbos y se caen
entonces analizando un poco el tema y
tratando de ver qué podía aportar como
los podía ayudar noté un factor común
todos o la gran mayoría no habían
trabajado para nadie había venían de un
trabajo que no estaban del todo
contentos o sean o no estaban conformes
en el lugar donde trabajaban
y ustedes se preguntarán qué tiene esto
de factor común
para que se entienda mejor mi punto les
voy a contar una anécdota cuando yo
termino la escuela y me tengo que ir a
estudiar para poder bancar los estudios
tuve que trabajar
consigue un trabajo en una empresa en la
que rápidamente pude ascender
y me fueron dando más responsabilidades
hasta el punto en que mi jefe se iba de
vacaciones y yo me quedaba a cargo de
todo el negocio
por cuestiones de la vida
cuando volví a esquel
quise poner mi propio negocio lo hice y
duró seis meses en ese momento me
frustré mucho porque yo venía de
trabajar de lo mismo ya lo hacía para
otra persona porque no lo puede hacer
para mí que le ponía a la vida
y en ese momento no lo pude entender y
es que hay algo sin importar tu
capacidad sin importar tus recursos que
nadie puede acelerar y eso es la
experiencia les voy a hacer una
representación para que vean lo que digo
bien el chiquito árbol ya está la meta
subir al árbol tengo que conquistar esa
rama vale se sube la verdad
la mamá hijo bájate de ahí que te vas a
caer
no mamá no me pasa nada se caen entonces
ahí las madres con ese instinto maternal
que la naturaleza les dio a través de
miles y miles de años vienen y te dicen
alguien sabe claro
ojalá que te hayas partido la cabeza en
cuatro partes así te deja de
pero lo que sucedió es que ella ya lo
vivieron y pese a que nos advirtieron no
no lo pudieron transmitir
y es que la experiencia tiene eso no se
puede transmitir tampoco si lo podemos
hacer con el conocimiento pero no con la
experiencia tenemos que vivirlo por
nuestra propia cuenta y caernos para
aprender la lección
pasó el tiempo y nuevamente me inserta
en el mercado laboral pero esta vez con
una particularidad la empresa donde
empecé a empezar a trabajar me dicen
claudio que queremos tomar queremos que
vos formes parte pero hay un detalle no
te podemos pagar
pequeños detalles
bueno en mi casa no me quería ni ver
entonces digo bueno igual
cuando empiezo a trabajar
para poder lograr que me paguen
necesitaba el dinero empiezo a
fortalecer mucho las ventas tratar de
desarrollar nuevas unidades de negocio y
sin darme cuenta fortalece uno de los
que considero los tres pilares para un
negocio exitoso que es la venta
el tiempo corrió pase por otros empleos
hasta que finalmente en una empresa me
dicen
vamos a armar una nueva unidad de
negocio creemos que vos la lleves
adelante porque tenés mucha experiencia
en la venta en las unidades negocios
desde esa apertura de mercados todo el
campo en eso bueno entonces agarra y me
dice te vamos a poner por porcentaje ya
está yo dije esta es la mía de acá mujer
casa perro aspiradora robots ya está me
salve no me explotan más
pero
cuando empezamos a trabajar y pasó el
tiempo y tuvimos que hacer la primera
liquidación después de repartir un poco
el dinero de pagar los proveedores los
costos todo que teníamos los empleados
solamente quedaba un poco más
que mi sueldo como empleado para
repartir entonces acá nuevamente note
que me faltaba algo
y en ese momento
nuevamente no lo entendí pero lo que me
faltaba era el segundo pilar que es la
administración
y que podemos hacer frente a esto que no
podemos ni aprender ni acelerar
es tan simple como pertenecer y por qué
digo pertenecer y no trabajar porque la
diferencia está en cuanto nos
involucramos con las tareas que
desarrollamos
y un poco para
contar cómo siguió la historia yo
finalmente gracias a mi socio amigo
pudimos poner un negocio el cual al
tener los dos pilares fortalecidos por
lo único nos tuvimos que preocupar es
por el tercero que es el saber hacer del
negocio en que nos diferenciamos del
resto y de esa manera tener éxito
y para redondear un poco la idea
eso que mi mamá no me pudo transmitir y
que solamente luego vamos a aprender con
el tiempo
pero no con el transcurso del mismo
si no perteneciendo
con las organizaciones comisiones
cooperadoras todas las instituciones
tienen algo para enseñarnos así que
démosle tiempo a tiempo que tarde o
temprano llega nuestro momento y tampoco
nos quedemos abrazado al árbol
porque si nos llegamos a caer siempre va
a estar nuestra familia y amigos para
darnos esas cálidas palabras de consuelo
muchas gracias